today is going to be a very busy very
long the day for these guys we decided
to plant 40 acres hopefully all the crop
comes up and you don't have to replant
anything one thing you got to worry
about is when you get out of the car as
soon as you do your glasses start to fog
up okay guys
dad's gonna go to work are you sad
no what did not have much luck here so
I'm getting ready to go and do what I
like to call the hunt and what that
really is is just shopping for supplies
I can tell you is everybody at the GM
plant is working as hard as we can to
meet the needs of the American consumers
[Music]
my dad and two uncles started the shop
in 1962 it's been so many years now and
we have four stores all in Southern
California it's really cool to see
expand it's just such a relief to be
able to go out and do what you still
love to do and get your mind off the
crazy time right now I'm heading about
three and a half hours to four hours
north into Arizona I'm an application
where I will deliver supplies I'm
looking forward to seeing my family and
just wish it were under better
circumstances I think everyone can look
at our world's economy and say that our
future is a little dim right now we are
planting knowing we will likely have a
loss this year that's a very scary thing
in an effort to really slow the numbers
or covet 19 they've decided to close all
tourist sites which includes the the
famed four corners monument I spent very
many summers here selling snow cones we
are setting up a basically a pickup
station cars pull up give us a phone
call and we bring out their orders
we want to go ahead and say okay is this
he doing okay what's going on so a lot
of times we'll take our four-wheelers
out and let's be honest
four-wheelers are fun even with the
restaurants and everything starting to
open up we decided that it wasn't time
to go out we're just not ready to not
practice a social distancing and this is
essentially how we have to say hello to
each other as opposed to the hugs as a
family so really good to be able to come
back and no hugs here practicing our
social distancing our oldest will have
his high school graduation this year
Charles Holman daresay jr. as much
change as they've had to endure is
they'll still be able to have that
graduation definitely been trying to
figure out things for kids to do do you
want me to turn bouncy house on for you
right now
[Music]
so we decided to convert our dining room
into a bouncy house
I leave the reservation and I leave my
home happy to say that there's hope and
that makes me proud to be a member of
the Navajo Nation and that our people
are continuing to remain positive and
continuing to be resilient I try to
always find the silver lining through
all of it
I've seen a community come together the
families are on bike rides I think it's
absolutely incredible that throughout
all this families are getting closer and
I just love it
[Music]